[Applaudissements]
à celle d'une gueule alors l'inconnu
devra coûter tous les soirs une histoire
une inconnue voilà qui est à la quête à
la télé qui nous a quelqu'un qui a
retenu notre attention aujourd'hui ces
histoires de marina à la 21 ans et une
jeune femme qu'on a découvert dans
confessions intimes
sa particularité se qualifie de bimbo
alors avec sa copine jennifer elle fait
tout pour ne jamais passer inaperçu
premier exemple lorsqu'elle prend sa
voiture regarder non c'est qu'à la scala
et maintenant direction le centre-ville
marina et jennyfer sont bien décidés à
se faire remarquer tu me reconnais j'ai
vu que j'avais moi type et on s'est
croisé mois se passait comme jésus -
avec jennifer marina passer et tu
t'écartes marine a dominé tutelle clean
je suis désolé mais si on ne voit pas
parce qu'on est aveugle
kalash calage c'est bon on est parti
alors voulez-vous la première explique
et en plus de la voiture marine a une
autre passion dans la vie c'est sortir
en boîte de nuit sont grands et c'est la
voiture est sortie en boîte de nuit
vous en avez comme ça des gens qui sont
passionnés par sa donc question pour un
champion
- et on pourra peut-être confié cette
jeune fille d'ouvrir un livre de temps
en temps elle le fait peut-être un le
fait peut-être alors vous allez voir
quand elle sort à la dore se faire
passer pour une star alors complètement
voilà avait béni gens ne la connaissent
pas encore peut-être les gens vous la
connaître mais regarde
william assouplies
c'est mort les descentes du monde car
dès qu'on passe quelque part les yeux
c'est sûr nous on est obligé de se
retourner baisse qui se recueillent se
retourne pas mais c'est qu'ils aient
voyais rien quoi il ya du travail pour
pascal le grand frère alors au lendemain
de sa soirée marina décide de faire un
peu de sport pour entretenir son corps
de rêve elle est plutôt jolie
ah oui oui une belle fille mes problèmes
elle refuse en fait à me faire du sport
mais marina il refuse de transpirer donc
à la semaine et c'est donc avec sa
copine pour faire du sport sans
transpirer regarder une question pour
les blondes dessus et maquillage oblige
mais 10
huit sacs la haye
non mais là on a perdu transféré en fait
et vous me dites que vous courrez tous
les matins moi non mais on constate
quand même on les remplit les bus tram
ce frère alors concédé mardi
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut pas compter sur sa technique
mais matthieu delormeau
non je ne connais pas mais c'est
vraiment ce genre d'émission c'est
ridicule parce que là évidemment que ces
légendes des filles qui veulent passer à
la télévision
douala façon tellement vrai on nous
interdisait de le faire avec eux des
gens qui veulent passer la télévision et
s'inventent des personnages ouais voilà
pour exister tout ça confessions intimes
alors yas marina qui se déplace elle
n'était pas gérée sur sa meilleure amie
que vous avez vu et la base entre amis
c'est d'avoir un check vous avez un
tchèque avec vos amis ou assez
convaincus tchèque vous moi donc c'est
tout comme l'offre
alors regardez celui de marina il est
magnifique regard des samu quatre heures
pour se préparer
c'est un film chinois bonjour je pense
au plumard que je vais passer la somme
et vous avez indiqué que vous avez vos
amis ou les personnes le tchèque kaboul
pour finir donc dans la ville marina n'y
a pas que ses amis il ya aussi ces
chiens et en fait elle fait tout pour
qu'il lui ressemble
elle va même jusqu'à les parfumer très
mauvais pour eux ça pour leur santé
bafoue tous le nord a annoncé la trouve
que la truffe est là dessus et fruits sa
part alors bafoue la preuve c'est ça
dans ta foot je vais chercher d'autres
termes merci pour ce retard pour
correspondre à l'image de la blonde
attitude 5h chauray chihuahua partagent
leur vie et pour sortir en famille les
chiens doivent eux aussi être impeccable
c'est à leur tour d'être bichonner ses
burkina voir faire
deux à temps il faut impérativement que
mes chiens soient assorties à moi
il faut qu'ils aient au moins quelque
chose à une couleur que mes habits on
qu'ils ont eux même si je sue sur la
tête qui s'affiche sur la tête c'est
magnifique
il faut qu'ils sont comme leur maman
quoi michael sarbach basque était passé
et à équiper en doc est repassé dans
confessions intimes et c'est vrai que
voilà on s'est demandé voix ce qui était
devenu alors eh ben on n'a pas su tirer
vous dira demain voilà près de nîmes à
rien mais on est sûr enquête parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle a certainement
évoluer le pire est que c'était énorme
déçu du parfois pour schirrhein très
vite très importants ils savaient qu'ils
aient de l'eau de l'icco mais comme ça
dans les hôtels tout ça oui eh ben ils
en on en voit maintenant avec des
phéromones dedans vous mettez de l'eau
de ligne est comme ça et lorsque vous
rentrez dans l'île la personne de
manière inconsciente sommes que c'est a
envie à une envie sexuelle comme ça et
donc teddy big man ap si vous l'amener
dans votre lit paf vous allez plonger
mon sujet en parfums là je l'espère sur
les plateaux et la personne sort dit